Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Tasha: 背点有什么呢
Tasha: What's the point of carrying this?
Tasha:  这个背着这个也背着
Tasha: Carrying this and that too
Tasha:  剩下的就算了
Tasha: Forget about the rest
Tasha:  耳机
Tasha: Headphones
Tasha:  ok就这样子下楼
Tasha: Okay, let's go downstairs like this
Lucia: 我怎么又找不到自己的手机
Lucia: Why can't I find my phone again?
Alice:你要去哪呢
Alice: Where are you going?
Tasha: 恩，哪也不去
Alice:你要出门吗
Alice: Are you going out?
Tasha: 连个凳都没有，不去
Alice:啊老板呢
Alice: Ah, where's the boss?
Tasha: 他，他随便
Alice:他在上面那啥吗
Alice: Is he upstairs doing something?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know
Tasha:  没看见我也不知道
Tasha: I haven't seen him, I have no idea
Alice:我以为他要开始录了
Alice: I thought he was going to start recording
Tasha: 他是不是好几天没发工钱了
Tasha: Hasn't he paid us for several days?
Alice:发什么工钱
Alice: Paid us for what?
Tasha: 工钱
Tasha: Wages
Alice:工钱工资
Alice: Wages, salary
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Alice:嗯应该是最后统一结吧
Alice: Hmm, probably he’ll pay all at once at the end
Alice:哎呦这样嗑瓜子好不舒服呀
Alice: Ugh, eating these sunflower seeds is so uncomfortable
Alice:所以老板老板设置的那种红包
Alice: So the boss set up those red envelopes
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Alice:是为是仪式感吗
Alice: Was it for some kind of ceremony?
Tasha: 可能吧
Tasha: Maybe
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 平板呢
Tasha: The tablet?
Tasha: 平板平板
Tasha: The tablet, the tablet
Tasha: 平板
Tasha: Tablet
Tasha: 哦我没那平板是吧
Tasha: Oh, I don't have that tablet, right?
Tasha: 嗯你朋友呢
Tasha: Hmm, where's your friend?
Alice:回去打第五人格了啊
Alice: Went back to play Identity V
Tasha: 啊他不跟你
Tasha: Ah, not with you?
Alice:搁那呢刘婷你在吗
Alice: Over there. Liu Ting, are you there?
Tasha: 哦哦
Tasha: Oh, oh
其他人：怎么了
Others: What's up?
Alice:想你啊
Alice: I miss you
Shure: 爬上去了
Shure: Climbed up.
其他人：你想我多看看我
Others: Do you want me to look more?
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
Alice:我看到你来火
Alice: I saw you get excited.
Alice:打第五人格吗
Alice: Playing Identity V?
Alice:能打的动不能
Alice: Can you even play?
其他人： 网卡成这样根本打不动
Others: The internet is so slow, we can't play at all.
Alice:我给你开热点
Alice: I can share my hotspot.
Tasha: 无线网吗
Tasha: Wi-Fi?
Alice:唉这无线网跟没有差不多
Alice: Ugh, this Wi-Fi is practically useless.
其他人：算了放回去吧
Others: Forget it, let's put it back.
Alice:但我热点还行
Alice: But my hotspot's okay.
Alice:求求我
Alice: Beg me.
Alice:你求我一下
Alice: Just beg me a bit.
其他人：不求
Others: No way.
Alice:不求拉到
Alice: Fine, forget it.
其他人：你着窗帘还真是
Others: Your curtain is really...
Alice:又掉了
Alice: It fell again.
Alice:没掉没啊我靠
Alice: It didn't fall... oh, come on.
Alice:是那个白的还是绿的呀
Alice: Is it the white one or the green one?
其他人：都掉了
Others: Both fell.
Alice:呵呵
Alice: Heh.
Alice:你能帮我粘一下吗
Alice: Can you help me stick it?
Alice:你可以了对吧
Alice: You can do it, right?
Alice:什么时候拍什么时候再粘
Alice: We'll fix it when we start filming.
Tasha: 14减7
Alice:咳一会不是渴不渴了
Alice: Cough, not thirsty anymore.
Tasha: 知道为什么这伙食这么好
Tasha: Do you know why the food here is so good?
Tasha: 可是我却食欲大减
Tasha: But I've lost my appetite.
Alice:累的
Alice: Because you're tired.
Tasha: 不知道我在学校伙食还没这好呢
Tasha: I don't know, the food at school wasn't this good, but I ate more there.
Tasha: 天天吃的比这多
Tasha: I ate more every day.
Alice:我觉得这在这吃饭太油了
Alice: I think the food here is too greasy.
Alice:感觉这几天身体负担很重
Alice: I feel like my body is so heavy these days.
Tasha: 啊所以什么都吃不下感觉
Tasha: Ah, so you can't eat anything.
Alice:回去我得吃几天素刷刷油
Alice: When I get back, I need to eat vegetarian for a few days to cleanse the oil.
Alice:对呀说了不磕了
Alice: Yeah, I said I wouldn't do it.
Alice:还磨我得远离这
Alice: Still bothering me, I need to stay away from this.
Alice:洗洗手
Alice: Wash my hands.
Alice:一开始
Alice: At the beginning...
Alice:不经意心就飘过去
Alice: My mind just drifted away unintentionally.
Alice:婷你在吗
Alice: Ting, are you there?
Alice:干嘛开门
Alice: Why did you open the door?
Alice:付费开门
Alice: Pay to open the door.
Alice:别坐在里面不出声
Alice: Don't just sit inside silently.
Alice:我知道你在家
Alice: I know you're home.
Alice:开门
Alice: Open the door.
Alice:哼我靠
Alice: Hmph, damn it.
Alice:怎么掉的越来越多
Alice: Why is it falling more and more?
Alice:真是麻烦
Alice: This is really troublesome.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Damn it.
Tasha: 好难啊
Tasha: This is so hard.
Tasha: A不到这个破绽死了
Tasha: Can't get an A, dead from this flaw.
其他人：你别讹我
Others: Don't blame me.
其他人：呀哈都录着呢哈哈哈
Others: Haha, it's all being recorded, haha.
Tasha: 死了
Tasha: 死了死了必死
Tasha: Dead, dead, definitely dead.
Tasha: 穿插上了
Tasha: Got in.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Damn it.
Tasha: 输了
Tasha: Lost.
Tasha: 这是真牛逼
Tasha: This is really awesome.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Damn it.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 死了
Tasha: Dead.
Tasha: 48382
Tasha: 死了
Tasha: Dead.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 难崩
Tasha: Hard collapse.
Tasha: 靠我上手
Tasha: Damn, I'm starting.
Tasha: 我的妈呀这
Tasha: Oh my god, this...
Tasha: 果
Tasha: Fruit.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Damn it.
Tasha: 伤害刚刚没跟上
Tasha: The damage didn't follow up just now.
Tasha: 我们把时间拖过去就赢了
Tasha: If we drag out the time, we win.
Tasha: 亲亲亲
Tasha: Kiss kiss kiss.
Jake:你怎么还背个小包包
Jake: Why are you still carrying a small bag?
Tasha: 这个包就跟我英装的发卡一样哦
Tasha: This bag is just like my hairpin with my outfit.
Tasha: 背上之后就好看是吧
Jake:对确实
Jake: Yeah, indeed.
Tasha: 有点有点高再矮一点
Tasha: A bit high, a little lower.
Tasha: 扫描房间吗
Tasha: Scanning the room?
Jake:二楼也要打扫
Jake: The second floor needs to be cleaned too.
Tasha: 才能够扫是吗
Tasha: Only then can we clean it, right?
Jake:走我们去开工充电
Jake: Let's go, we need to get started and charge up.
Tasha: 我们吗
Tasha: We are going?
Tasha: 就我们俩吗
Tasha: Just the two of us?
Jake:再抓几个我们先去
Jake: We'll grab a few more people, let's go first.
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 走吧
Tasha: Let's go.
Jake:走吧首先看一下我的这个
Jake: Let's go, first, take a look at this.
Tasha: 啊首先看一下我的这个
Tasha: Ah, first, take a look at this.
Jake:哇去
Jake: Wow.
Jake:这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Tasha: 不知道
Tasha: No idea.
Tasha: 走吧
Tasha: Let's go.
Tasha: 不开
Tasha: It won't open.
Tasha: 靠这小架子感觉已经是这的
Tasha: This small shelf feels like it's already part of the place.
Tasha: 你到现在没开
Tasha: You haven't opened it yet?
Jake:我刚刚在
Jake: I was just...
Jake:这个
Jake: This...
Tasha: 在
Tasha: 没电了
Tasha: The battery's dead.
Tasha: 充电了吗
Tasha: Charged it?
Jake:嗯充了
Jake: Yeah, it's charged.
Tasha: 像那个拍摄助手
Tasha: Like that filming assistant.
Tasha: 嗯拍这个吗
Tasha: Are we filming this?
Jake:哼哼
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:走上楼
Jake: Let's go upstairs.
Jake:惨不忍睹是吧
Jake: It's a mess, right?
Tasha: 需要一个袋子
Tasha: We need a bag.
Jake:把这个电脑装起来
Jake: Pack up this computer.
Tasha: 确实
Tasha: Indeed.
Tasha: 怎么就剩了一个麦克风
Tasha: Why is there only one microphone left?
Tasha: 巴啦啦啦啦啦
Tasha: Ba la la la la la.
Tasha: 有没有可能我们首先需要一个
Tasha: Is it possible we first need a...
Tasha: 垃圾袋
Jake:但是呢
Jake: But then...
Tasha: 哪里有
Tasha: Where can we find one?
Jake:在哪里会有呢
Jake: Where would we find one?
Jake:拿个箱子过来跟他们学怎么样
Jake: Get a box and learn from them, how about that?
Jake:你等着
Jake: Wait here.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Jake:你等着我去拿个箱子上来
Jake: Wait, I'll go get a box.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: the true love
Tasha: The true love.
Jake:哎呀你好
Jake: Hey, hello.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Shure: 咋了啊你
Shure: What's up with you?
Shure: 头晕真的只是喝多了
Shure: Dizzy from drinking too much?
Shure: 没有问题的啊
Shure: No problem at all.
Tasha: 这有一个浪费鬼
Tasha: There's a wasteful ghost here.
Shure: 我买了西瓜
Shure: I bought a watermelon.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Okay, thanks.
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 大家切瓜吃瓜吧
Shure: Everyone, let's cut and eat the watermelon.
Jake:好吃吃瓜多吃瓜
Jake: Sure, let's eat more watermelon.
Tasha: 呼吸大
Tasha: Breathe deeply.
Jake:音响收一收
Jake: Turn down the volume.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Got it.
Tasha: 我没听见
Tasha: I didn't hear it.
Shure: 那要镇上吗
Shure: Should we chill the watermelon?
Shure: 那个西瓜
Shure: That watermelon.
Jake:huh
Jake: Huh?
Shure: 那西瓜要镇一下吗
Shure: Should we chill that watermelon?
Jake:可以啊
Jake: Sure.
Shure: 怎么镇
Shure: How do we chill it?
Shure: 哎呀捡钱了
Shure: Oh, found some money.
Jake:这个小架子是哪来的呀
Jake: Where did this little shelf come from?
Tasha: 他房间的
Tasha: From his room.
Jake:哦你房间有个小夹子
Jake: Oh, you have a little clip in your room.
Lucia: 对对本来是有个这样的小架子
Lucia: Yes, there was a small shelf like this.
Lucia: 他实在是太难装饰好看了
Lucia: It was really hard to decorate nicely.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 然后我就换成一个小小的柜子
Lucia: So I replaced it with a small cabinet.
Lucia: 给他铺了一个那个啥
Lucia: And put something on it.
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK OK.
Lucia: 这个我就拿出来了
Lucia: So I took this out.
Jake:太妙了
Jake: That's great.
Jake:然后给给薇薇用了
Jake: And then gave it to Tasha to use.
Lucia: 然后昨天刚好可以用来放甜点
Lucia: And then yesterday we could use it to put desserts.
Jake:太妙了呀
Jake: That's awesome.
Jake:这个应该也是记录了下来
Jake: This should be recorded too.
Jake:在你们俩的眼镜中
Jake: In both of your glasses.
Lucia: 对应该是我搬出来的时候
Lucia: Yeah, probably when I moved it out.
Lucia: 我记得我戴眼镜了
Lucia: I remember wearing glasses.
Lucia: 因为昨天上午我一直在装修房子
Lucia: Because I was renovating the house all morning yesterday.
Jake:妙啊妙啊妙啊
Jake: Brilliant, brilliant, brilliant.
Lucia: 现在是不是又要该收拾一下
Lucia: Should we tidy up again now?
Jake:对二楼再收拾一下就可以
Jake: Yeah, just tidy up the second floor and we're good.
Jake:就可以吃西瓜了
Jake: Then we can eat watermelon.
Lucia: 好耶
Lucia: Yay.
Jake:修硕了几个西瓜
Jake: Shure got a few watermelons.
Jake:一个西瓜
Jake: One watermelon.
Jake:没有几个西瓜
Jake: No, a few watermelons.
Lucia: 几个西瓜
Lucia: A few watermelons.
Jake:一个西瓜
Jake: One watermelon.
Jake:没电了又
Jake: Power's out again.
Jake:啥时候买没关系
Jake: Whenever you buy it, it's fine.
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's fine.
Lucia: 这个是谁的呀
Lucia: Whose is this?
Katrina: 这个要拿下去吗
Katrina: Should I take this down?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Katrina: 这个拿下去吗
Katrina: Should I take this down?
Tasha: 嗯好像是的拿来
Tasha: Yeah, I think so, bring it here.
Katrina: 糖吃的
Katrina: It's candy.
Tasha: 拿下去洗就行了
Tasha: Just take it down and wash it.
Tasha: 还有什么要
Tasha: Anything else we need?
Tasha: 嗯这个能给带下去吗
Tasha: Can this be taken down too?
Tasha: was a too late
Tasha: Was it too late?
Tasha: 啪啪啪啪啪啪
Tasha: Pa pa pa pa pa pa.
Katrina: 可是昨天真的就只一点点
Katrina: But really, it was just a little bit yesterday.
Jake:刮刮乐没买到
Jake: Didn't get the scratch-off ticket.
Jake:买了个瓜这
Jake: Got a melon instead.
Jake:强一些应该
Jake: Should be stronger.
Shure: 呀我是李轩
Shure: Oh, I'm Li Xuan.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Jake:好嘞三九几个呀
Jake: Alright, how many 3-9s do we have?
Tasha: 把平板拿出来
Tasha: Get the tablet out.
Jake:上面应该5个吗 12345
Jake: There should be five on top. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Shure: 把我这些印象什么的都收一下
Shure: Pack up all my stuff and impressions.
Jake:弄下去两个
Jake: Move two down.
Jake:这小马就放上面吧弄下去
Jake: Let's put the little horse on top and move it down.
Jake:哎一个house
Jake: Oh, a house.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Jake:对冰刮了
Jake: Yes, the ice has been scraped.
其他人：我找到了找到那个视频了
Others: I found it! Found the video!
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
收拾一下
Let's tidy up.
其他人：所以这么多凳子摆的开吗
Others: So, can we fit all these chairs?
Jake:要搬下去两个
Jake: We need to move two down.
其他人：哦要搬下去
Others: Oh, move them down.
Lucia: 啊怎么
Lucia: Huh, what?
Lucia: 他有影响到什么吗
Lucia: Did it affect anything?
Jake:他没有影响到什么
Jake: It didn't affect anything.
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Jake:他就放了进去
Jake: He just put it in.
Jake:对我要扫楼
Jake: Yes, I need to sweep the floor.
Jake:他这个这
Jake: This, this...
Shure: 这个这
Shure: This, this...
Shure: 这波的建模
Shure: The modeling of this batch.
Lucia: 这也可以放回我房间里
Lucia: This can also go back to my room.
Shure: 和上一波的建模有什么区别
Shure: What's the difference in modeling between this batch and the last?
Jake:那你觉得有什么区
Jake: What do you think the difference is?
Jake:你你房间确实没什么区别
Jake: Your room really has no difference.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Jake:你房间可以不扫
Jake: You don't need to sweep your room.
Jake:哈哈哈什么
Jake: Hahaha, what?
Jake:你刚刚说啥
Jake: What did you just say?
Lucia: 我说这个就是如果影响
Lucia: I said, if it affects...
Lucia: 你可以放回我房间里
Lucia: You can put it back in my room.
Jake:不影响不影响
Jake: It doesn't affect anything.
Lucia: 因为我是在收拾
Lucia: Because I'm tidying up.
Lucia: 所以先把它拿出来了
Lucia: So I took it out first.
Jake:不影响不影响
Jake: It doesn't affect anything.
Jake:就是除了你的房间和厕所
Jake: Except for your room and the bathroom.
Jake:别的都有巨大的变化
Jake: Everything else has changed a lot.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 这跟病例有关系
Lucia: This is related to the case.
Shure: 这会说话的呀
Shure: This can talk!
Jake:不是事实是这么回事
Jake: No, the fact is this.
Lucia: 你是懂修辞的
Lucia: You understand rhetoric.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我是不是有个卡子
Lucia: Do I have a clip?
Lucia: 还啊对
Lucia: Oh yeah.
Lucia: 在这算了
Lucia: It's here, forget it.
Lucia: 先这样吧
Lucia: Let's just leave it for now.